hi everyone
uh welcome to this uh discussion session
uh of our monthly inference colloquium
uh
and for those of uh you who are joining
us
uh after yesterday's lecture as you know
this session
serves as a forum for conversation
between our speaker
and a conversant uh which we all witness
share and ask questions to clarify
to expand and extend uh the remit of the
lecture
so we were really deeply honored uh and
it was a privilege to listen
to eric winsberg talk yesterday
about causal inference in complex
non-linear systems
a cautionary tale so i would like to
um briefly um remind you all
first that since we are recording this
event
uh that all participants must mute their
videos
and as always please feel free to start
typing in your questions
into the chat and we will pick them up
um right after eric and
our wonderful uh conversation today
stephanie
have uh concluded their own uh sort of
discussions
so we are utterly delighted and it's a
real honor
to have a dr stephanie harvard who is
a michael smith foundation health
research postdoctoral fellow at the
university of british columbia
and the faculty of pharmaceutical
sciences there she received a phd in
population and public health in a joint
program between the university of
british columbia
and the university university pier and
mahikuri
in paris well what a lovely combination
of city stephanie
uh in 2017. her current focus
um research focus is on the implications
of philosophy's values
in science literature for health
economics modeling
and knowledge translation and her
post-doctoral work
current work focuses on creating
educational videos to communicate the
role of social and ethical values
in modeling and exploring new ways of
informing health economics models to
patient
and public values she also co-leads a
project
a novel mechanism to support
transformative model interrogation in
patient-oriented health economics
which is funded by the bc unit health
economics unit and simulation
and methods cluster she also happens to
be the co-author
with professor windsberg of the
representational risk paper
which um on his talk page which is on
um and you can see that that article
actually on
our talk page on the inference website
and so together they have also
co-authored
an earlier paper on public participation
in health modeling
design um and you might see
in just a minute if i remind you of uh
professor winsberg's research interest
and uh briefly tell you a little bit
about what he
presented yesterday how apt a conversant
uh stephanie is for the work that was
discussed yesterday
as you all know uh professor winsberg is
a historian and philosopher of science
and he um has been interested
in the philosophy of climate change
philosophy of physics and more generally
broadly philosophy of science
but in particular the role of computer
simulations and modeling in the physical
sciences
his work in the philosophy of climate
science relates to
the application of models and
simulations to science policy and ethics
so his work has always been
trying to see the how scientific
models are used to inform
policy decisions and of course over the
last several months
um you know um eric had um
enormous bounty in terms of research
project
falling into his lap from multiple
directions which
is the pandemic and the associated data
policy responses uh to it
and the just the way in which the
pandemic outcomes how they have unfolded
so he talked to us um about
the work that he has done using models
and methods
of causal inference um in the covid
in the unfolding covert 19 pandemic
and in yesterday's talk he demonstrated
our
blind spots in how we leap to inferring
causality
and how our directions of inquiry and
how we
use the data to inform the kinds of
judgments and value assessments that we
want to make
that in turn shape or are
intended to shape uh public behavior
so um without much further ado
um stephanie i invite you to
um start this discussion session okay
thank you so much priya i'm gonna share
my screen
and i'm just gonna double check that i'm
able to advance
okay great okay so like priya said
um this is a conversation today about
eric when uh whispers talk from
yesterday which was called
causal inference in complex nonlinear
systems a
cautionary tale so for future viewers
who haven't seen that talk you can go
and access that on youtube
for the full details um for my
discussion today i'm going to follow the
standard
two segment format for this talk series
so
the first is the in other words segment
where i'm going to give you the gist of
what i think
eric was saying yesterday and then i'll
do the
so now what segment where i'm going to
try to draw out some of the implications
of eric's discussion um this is a
picture of little red riding hood
because i'm told that it's a cautionary
tale in itself
roughly to the effect of don't talk to
strangers
so one of my goals for today is to help
us zero in on the nature of
eric's uh cautionary tale
okay so in the big picture what was
eric's key message yesterday
well i think it was that causal
inference
in complex nonlinear systems is more
difficult than we wish it was
and it's certainly more difficult than
is convenient for us
in policymaking and when we are engaged
in it
we're vulnerable to mistakes and this
has been shown in climate science
and in epidemiology so
one of the first examples that eric's
that eric used
uh was from climate science where
between 1998 and 2012
there was this observation of what
seemed to be a hiatus
in global warming and as eric described
uh scientists were eager to advance many
different hypotheses
about what was causing this and as i've
done here
we might visualize uh these hypotheses
as the more attention-grabbing
characters at a party
but the moral of eric's story was that
you know it's not always the
attention-grabbing hypotheses that are
the correct ones
right and in the case of this observed
hiatus and global warning
uh the best explanation was actually a
discreet character
ordinary internal variability
so during coven 19 many scientists have
turned to the question of
which population level interventions
have been
effective in curbing transmission
and i took the upshot of eric's talk to
be that
there's no good evidence right now um
that any of these have been effective
and we don't know how effective if they
have been
right um so once again the observed
differences
could be the result of this discrete
character
stephanie i just wanted to and this uh
wanted a clarification here for
both you and eric and eric this is in
uh this is you know other than complete
lockdown
right so that was clear would you agree
that the
what both of you agree that complete
lockdown
prevented transmission right
i mean i'm going to tell you my
interpretation works that
has not been uh shown well okay great
thanks
i just wanted to inspect there in the
event that you
we don't come to that question i want to
make sure uh i think i have a little
quote from a paper that that does go
into depth about that and we can
definitely bring that up in the
discussion i certainly did not read
eric's talk as being you know that that
even that has been shown
um but eric's talk gives us this chance
to go
through some of the challenges that come
up in addressing
these types of questions broadly right
so very often in population health
research
the questions don't lend themselves to
randomization they don't lend themselves
to randomized study designs
and that's either because they're not
ethical or just because they're not
feasible
so we need another way to control for
confounding
if we're trying to do causal inference
now one big class of techniques
basically tries to exploit
some source of arbitrary variation
in who gets the treatment uh and who
doesn't sort of like across
jurisdictions
across different regions and times so
eric focused on two such methods
yesterday
uh the first being the difference in
differences method and the second being
uh synthetic control
so with the did methods basically we're
trying
to identify sort of a natural treatment
group natural control group
um like a place that implemented a mass
policy and
and one that didn't and then you know
we're trying to compare them
in terms of the change in the outcome uh
before and after
the intervention was implemented and
then
with synthetic control methods the focus
is similar
but instead of using one or two uh
specific
real world control groups there's a data
driven method
for stitching together numerous control
groups into one in a synthetic way
so basically identifying multiple
control units that
the analyst thinks you know had similar
characteristics
had a similar outcome trajectory prior
to the intervention similar to the
treatment group
um and then doing a weighted average
so the advantage of the difference in
differences method is that
in theory it's able to account for
confounding
uh between treatment and control as long
as confounders are fixed over time
but the flip side is that you have to be
able to assume
that there's no sudden changes in
confounders so
as eric explained uh this is called the
parallel trans assumption
and it basically means that we have to
assume that you know without the
intervention
the outcomes for the treated and the
control groups you know would have been
following
parallel trajectories over time
now the synthetic control oh no some
reason i
suddenly can't advance guy do you know
why that would be i suddenly
can't advance oh i think it may because
of
someone going in their waiting room any
suggestions
and i admitted that person let's see
okay maybe try now yeah okay now i'm
good
that's okay thank you so synthetic
control methods
have several requirements i'm not going
to go through them they're all detailed
in the abadi article that eric
circulated
um but the point that eric was
emphasizing yesterday
was that among the requirements there
are two in particular
that are sort of in tension with each
other so
first of all there need to be
appropriate comparators available
so to add into this synthetic donor pool
there need to be available comparators
that are you know they have similar
attributes to the treatment group
now second of all there can't be
interference
in the sense of spillover effects of the
intervention
so there can't be sort of a phenomenon
where people are watching and they're
seeing that the intervention is
happening elsewhere
and they're sort of taking it upon
themselves to do it too
so yesterday eric put up a quote from
abedi and i'll do the same here
um so viewers can maybe pause the video
and read this quote for a good
explanation summary of this tension that
we're talking about
okay so so in a nutshell
i think eric was emphasizing yesterday
that methods for causal inference have
requirements and it's risky business
to be pretending that we satisfy those
requirements when we don't
so that was the takeaway i think and i
think we might
understand this in terms of epistemic
limitations
which is a big picture problem in
population health research and i i want
to connect this to an article from last
year from
a group led by mathay this was a review
of methods that are commonly used in
population health research
and they clustered them into two main
strategies so
these are these instrument based
approaches like the ones that eric was
talking about yesterday
um and then there's the the methods that
are known as confounder control
approaches
um and their conclusion was ultimately
that you know
all of these methods rely in one way or
another on
some unverifiable assumptions and
further to that there are trade-offs
involved in choosing what method to use
and ultimately having different lines of
evidence from different study designs
is probably the best that we can do
they also made another note which i
think is important
which is that in their experience um
researchers in in population health they
tend to rely
on one or the other method right and
there's
often a lack of understanding of the
other method right
whatever method one does not specialize
there's often a lack of familiarity with
how it works
and this can be problematic because to
uh really interpret the evidence well in
population health
one needs to understand the trade-offs
that are inherent in the different
methods
okay so there's limitations in our
methods
but there are also limitations in our
capacities right
and i want to connect this to a paper
that i think is relevant i know it's on
eric's
uh radar um so this is a critique
that came out of a model that was
focusing
um on the efficacy of of different covet
interventions or you know npis right
and you know these authors write
you know we conclude that the model is
in effect too
flexible and therefore allows the data
to be explained in various ways
and this has led the authors to go
beyond the data in reporting that
particular
interventions are especially effective
and
they say this kind of error mistaking
assumptions for conclusions
is easy to make and not especially easy
to catch
so that's a point i want to put on the
table
um okay so moving on to the
so now what segment um i think there are
a number of different directions that we
could take this conversation
and that includes ideas like how can we
overcome these limitations
uh but instead of doing that today i
want to steer towards
some normative questions because i think
they relate to a number of themes that
we see coming out in eric's recent work
and particularly the three papers that
he circulated in advance of the talk so
on the bottom of the screen here i've
put the sort of truncated titles of
those three papers
um and i just want to distill
a few key messages from all of those
papers
so first of all scientific models
broadly construed they're not sort of
truth apt
things right they're evaluated in terms
of
adequacy for purpose and this emphasizes
that modeling is evaluated activity uh
both because purposes are evaluated and
and so
are notions of adequacy so
there's a corresponding risk there and
that's the risk that
modeling decisions decisions that come
up in the modeling process
and ultimately models themselves are
going to be
inadequate for purpose now eric and i
call this
representational risk and we distinguish
it from
inductive risk uh which we take to be
the risk of endorsing a false fact so
the argument there is that there's an
advantage to understanding those risks
as different
even though we might want to draw
connections between them and even though
they both give us insight into the role
of values and modeling and
values in science okay so third
eric has argued alongside some
co-authors
um that in certain contexts
our epistemic standards should actually
be quite high
so for example when it comes to
restricting civil liberties
it might be acceptable to do this just
on the basis of precautionary reasoning
for a certain amount of time but after a
certain point
this ceases to be acceptable and in the
long run
governments are only justified in
restricting civil liberties
on the basis of good scientific evidence
so not just
you know the best available evidence but
good
good scientific evidence and also on a
careful and transparent
you know cost effectiveness analysis
which of course is another normative
enterprise um and then the last point
you know in the cost of learning paper
that he circulated
eric offers up a framework to help us
think about the expected net benefits of
research
and this is taking into consideration
that you know monetary costs of research
are not the only relevant costs
so eric uses the term ungoodian costs to
describe
sort of non-monetary costs of research
and he's given us some reasons to think
that under some conditions research
could have
a negative expected utility so two
specific examples of ungoodian costs
that i think are relevant for today uh
the first is the possibility that
the results of research might be taken
as being
stronger evidence than we think is right
and so basically if we think that
decision makers
are going to effectively misinterpret
the evidence then research could have a
negative expected utility for us
um and further to that another on goody
and cost
might be something like negative
externalities
so for example maybe research is going
to signal something
that we don't want it to signal and if
that's the case
again maybe research could have a
negative expected utility
i think i'm going to have my same uh
slide advancing problem folks
oh there we go okay so now that we know
these terms that eric uses um i just
want to sort of riff off
them and present an imaginary scenario
to get us thinking about
um some of these normative questions
okay so first for the sake of argument
let's just imagine a model
where we all know that the requirements
for causal inference are not
met so the model is not adequate for
causal inference
now interestingly it seems like one way
to
evade representational risk is to just
say that the model has a different
purpose so
i'm thinking of something a bit
analogous to something that we've seen
in covid modeling which is to basically
say
you know well the model wasn't for
prediction it was for
conditional projection so then if a
model said something like
you know under conditions abc we would
see
x number of infections or x number of
deaths
um but then those conditions don't
materialize those outcomes don't
materialize in the world
um there seems to be no grounds upon
which we can object
so when it comes to models that don't
satisfy the requirements for causal
inference
um i think maybe we can imagine
something or more than one thing that
would be analogous to that
so for me a few distinct possibilities
come
to mind if we go ahead and we build this
model
so first the model gets genuinely
misinterpreted
it gets misinterpreted in good faith
maybe by policy makers
or scientists from another discipline
who think that causal inference is what
it's for
and they use it for that uh
second option maybe the model gets used
as a rhetorical device
so no one actually thinks the model can
support causal inference
but doing it anyway allows people to
advance their own preferred policies
and so they use the model to this end
and then third we might imagine that the
model just goes unused
so in other words everyone recognizes
the model's not for causal inference
causal inference is what they want and
so they just move on
so i think at the very least there's
probably some waste of money involved
there
um but there might be some negative
externalities too
so maybe in terms of what we signal to
the public
um and then finally you know since we're
imagining this
i think we need to imagine a few
contextual factors that are probably
relevant
um so the first that comes to my mind
would be the degree of epistemic opacity
um so to what degree is it possible
to know all of the epistemically
relevant elements of this model
maybe that degree of epistemic opacity
would change the picture
for us in some way uh
second to what extent are various
agents directly engaging with the model
and doing their own assessments of
adequacy for purpose
because it seems like in many contexts
it's actually a relatively small number
of people
who are really looking under the hood of
the model
and a relatively large number of people
who are just relying on epistemic trust
and in fact this seems to be a standard
feature of current
you know epistemically distributed uh
research and policy making context
now three assuming that this is a policy
oriented model
to what extent do people agree or
disagree
about what counts as a benefit so this
seems relevant particularly in contexts
um you know like mass mandates it seems
like people deeply disagree
about what should be counted as a cost
and what should be counted as a benefit
when it comes to wearing masks so
for example if mask wearing affords me
a level of perceived comfort does that
make it on the ledger or not
um beyond that there seems to be some
disagreement about
what price we should be prepared to pay
for what level of benefit so even for
example let's say we had perfect
knowledge
that masks cause a five percent
reduction in coveted infections
would that mean that we should implement
a mask policy
so it seems like there's at least not
not
good agreement there or not good
evidence of agreement
um finally i think we should just get it
on the table that you know again people
do say
we need complementary evidence from
different study designs
to support robust causal inferences so
maybe there are some of us who would
carve out a role for models
um that they don't allow causal
inference themselves but
maybe in some way they would help us
reason things out down the road maybe
or possibly in combination with
something else
okay so this leads me to pose eric a few
direct questions and maybe he can pick
you know which ones interest him um so
first
you know i'd like to know if you think
it's legitimate to
assign a causal model a different
purpose to evade representational risk
um also do you think that there are
conditions
under which you know models of complex
linear systems would maybe have a
negative expected utility
um finally sort of a two-part question
you know can we do a better job
of articulating epistemic standards uh
in modeling for
causal inference and then what about
epistemic standards
in the policy making context so on the
latter points
i am thinking about a couple of things
in particular um
i'm wondering you know do we need to
specify the model purpose in advance
um does it need to be done in a
particular level of detail
um do we need to spell out what are
legitimate purposes for models
and do we need to set standards around
who should be involved
in determining whether a model is
adequate for purpose
so those are just some ideas to get the
ball rolling uh these are the references
that i mentioned if anyone would like
them
and i will toss it over to eric
um thank you so much yeah thank you so
much stephanie for these wonderful
comments so eric please um
slide again oh yeah yeah i guess i have
to
press share screen again is that
convenient for everyone is that right
is there any disadvantage to my being
the one that shares it again
okay good so yeah so the first question
i think is tricky um because
uh i think when you uh do something like
that so in other words the idea is like
could i use
could i take a model um that you know
looks like uh it's uh its job is to
um you know attribute causes to
something
uh but it's not adequate for that and
then mitigate
the the damage of that by by being clear
that this is not what the
what the model is for um one thing this
makes me think of just maybe i'll
back back up to climate so
um in climate science there's a kind of
long standing history of these things
called
the rcps the representative
carbon pathways i think what it stands
for i'll tell you i might have that
wrong
and there's rcp 4.5 and rcp 6.5 and rcp
8.5
and um pretty clearly these pathways
were
picked you know way back i think in
maybe the early 90s maybe that far ago
i'm not sure um but there was
the idea that rcp 8.5 was often called
business as usual
uh and what it is right it's all it is
is it's just a project it's just a it's
just a graph
of carbon in the atmosphere from you
know the present
until the end of the 21st century and
it's pretty standard for you know client
models to run projections
on these uh on these on these rcps and
show you this is what the how
hot the world's going to be for rcp 4.5
this is how the world's going to be rcp
6.5
etc okay so some people have sort of
started to complain a little bit about
the fact that rcp 8.5
is still often in the toolkit um
even though it looks
uh even though it's not sorry what
i'm getting
could i just request everyone else to
mute their microphones please
that might help
i'm struggling to you mine because of my
i'm stuck on share
i don't think you're the problem seem to
have a really weird
i'm not one okay i don't know maybe not
anyway
uh good so so there's been some people
wondering why are we still doing
you know why are we still doing 8.5 um
given that it certainly seems as though
uh the world has made enough progress
that 8.5 doesn't really look like it's
in the cards
so in other words we haven't you know we
haven't had
the massive increase in in carbon output
that you know maybe people worried would
happen in the 90s and that's represented
in our cpa 8.5
and of course it's you know it's a
perfectly okay thing i think a lot of
people say this they say look these are
just pathways these are just story lines
you know 8.5 is just a it's just a
storyline we're not saying
there's no indication here that this is
what's going to happen these are not
predictions
these are just projections this is just
like if we were to do 8.5
this is what the world would do like and
i think there's a i think there's you
know that there's
you know of all the things that that
that um
you get in the climate to be i think
that's one where there's actually some
pretty honest debate that you need to be
had about that right
um why you know how
how how confident are we
to be that when we put um
things like that into the public domain
for consumption
that people will understand right that
8.5 doesn't really look like it's on the
table anymore
to what extent or should we should be
worried that they're going to think look
this is
this we know that some vaguely in our
you know in the back of our heads 8.5
is so-called business as usual so when i
see the projection
on the graph that's being circulated um
by
various climate uh scientists and
various um
uh labs uh why not think why why isn't
it reasonable for me to think that that
that highest
curve is what what i would like is what
i expect the world to behave
like um if we don't you know if we don't
make major changes
so i think that you know that's a tough
question right um
i think when you were when you were
putting a model out there and
you know handing it to policymakers not
just handing it to policymakers but
putting it out there for public
consumption
as a way of um you know and i don't
think i don't think it's
stretched to suggest that both climate
scientists and public health experts
over the last year
have been you know trying to influence
uh
public perceptions of what ought to be
uh
done
think i think there are interesting
questions there about what you know
whether it's legitimate to put a model
out there that
looks like it's doing a but in the fine
print right
it's like well actually we're not
actually claiming that we're making
causal inferences here
we're not actually claiming anymore that
this is business as usual
uh et cetera et cetera i i you know i do
think there's legitimate worries there
that you're now um you're now drifting
from uh
your job as someone who i take it you
know the standard line is
your job as an epistemic expert is to
provide us
with uh you know the best information
that we can get
um your job is not necessarily
right to um make
uh make a determination about what the
best
thing to encourage the best thing to get
people to
support policy because because
what the best thing to support policy is
always
you know as we all know obviously right
uh a combination of
right what what to believe and what to
value
right and so i just i think it's i think
it's i think there's a there's a there's
a fine line to be walked there
um about um when
uh you know when modeling efforts like
that
where something is a model is inadequate
for some purpose
the fine print just says that we're not
really using it for that purpose
but it sure looks like right sure looks
like for public consumption
that that's the purpose it's useful for
i think there's i think there are issues
there that you know
of sort of that's a
a possibly sneaky way of breaching that
line between informing people and
uh and sort of imposing your views of
what
the best balance of uh of course and
benefits
is um uh are there
are other conditions under which uh
models of complex resistance have
negative expected utility um
yeah i mean for sure there could be
right uh
i mean so the the the phrase on goody
and cost that stephanie mentioned
um uh it's just me kind of giving a more
formal decision theoretic framework to a
line of argument that comes from phil
kitcher
uh and pitcher was interested in the
question of you know
when when is it bad to do research into
um the you know natural
uh ability natural differences in
ability that exist between sexes and
races
um and he just mounts the argument that
you know this is generally speaking
research that's going to have negative
expected utility because
right um uh simply because the
you know when when when it looks like
there's evidence that there's no
difference
in abilities people tend to ignore it
when it looks like there's evidence that
there is abilities it makes every
newspaper it gets
on you know and every it blows up
everywhere
um and so there's a kind of much higher
probability of the
evidence being misinterpreted in one
direction than the other
and then there's a much higher cost of
being wrong
he thinks right on the research and i
agree with him there right um
if you're if you're if if there if there
are differences
uh and you wrongly point out that there
aren't
probably nothing is going to happen
anyway but if there aren't differences
then you point out there are you're
going to cause an enormous amount of
harm
right to people by by finding this out
so
so um so so that's that's the kind of
condition under which like you know a
knowledge
an evidence gathering practice can have
negative expected utility
um you know look over the last year we
have
engaged interventions that have been
enormously costly um to a lot of people
in a lot of places
uh you know particularly uh
there's i think been a phenomenon of the
following kind right where
um uh
you know public health experts in
developed countries
particularly let's say the united states
and the uk
have been trying to influence policy
here
uh and putting forth certain kinds of
models that showed
certain you know benefits to
interventions um
and then those interventions have been
tried in developing countries
i have in mind particularly india and
south africa
uh where those interventions were both
wildly unsustainable
so they had very low likelihood of
actually providing any benefit in the
long run
uh and had just enormous costs right so
we know about these things like
you know these death marches in india
that happened when
uh migrant workers were just cut off
from their jobs and their housing
and their transportation um so uh so so
yeah so i do
i do think that um i do think that uh
um when you in when you engage in
inference that
is that you kind of know in advance
uh that you don't really have good tools
for getting
reliable answers um you ought to think
hard about what the positive possible
negative
uh expect until you're just gathering
the evidences so i agree with catcher
about that
um can we do a better job of
articulating epistemic standards
modeling for causal inference
i mean i think this is tricky i think
one of the things that makes it
especially tricky
is that difference is a difference
between this is going to be a mouth a
muscle
the difference between difference and
difference and synthetic control methods
um i think you know one of the one of
the features
of synthetic control methods for causal
inference
is it looks like it looks like a magic
trick
right um but if you read the sort of
foundational
papers i guess i don't really know how
to pronounce his name
if you read like his foundational papers
on this he's quite clear
right that doing synthetic control
um requires a lot of skill on the part
of the
of the person making the donor pool for
the synthetic control method
and that if you don't exercise great
care in choosing that donor pool
you can show almost anything causes
anything else
um so i think you know that that
difference in difference math
so that that synthetic control method uh
has that disadvantage relative to a
difference in difference method
that it really requires quite a bit more
trust in the
uh in the in the in the modeler
uh it's a little bit harder to look
under the hood and see whether
uh things have been done in a way that
really does
eliminate the likelihood of compounds
there
um yeah and what about epistemic
standards and evidence of
policy making i mean look i think we
ought to be having
a lot of conversations about this i
don't know what the uh
i don't know what the magic wand is but
um uh i
i do think that you know a lot of these
uh
a lot of these with all the reasons
we've been talking about
a lot of these um
kinds of uh scientific work that
informed policy
uh can very quickly
look like they are evidence for a policy
choice
right and i think if you go back and say
look at like report nine
by the sage group in the uk uh that came
out i think march 19th 2020 right this
was the
the probably the most influential
scientific report
uh in the history of the world i don't
think that's an exaggeration
um it it very much reads like
you know an advocacy for a set of policy
choices
um and and it's it's i think quite clear
that
those policy choices involved balances
of costs and benefits
that uh for whom the stakeholders
were literally everybody in the world
uh so yeah i think that it's
it's it's important that we in
some way or other and i think we need to
be having a lot of conversations about
how the best way to do this is i don't
have the answers
but in some way or other we need to be i
think
thinking about the ways in which when
research like that is being done uh
you know that process of
um sort of the ways in which
values are entering into the into the
scientific inference itself
uh are in some way or another you know
getting at um getting at the
representative values because i think
you know i think one one thing that that
i've sort of had the growing
feeling of over the course of the last
14 or 16 or whatever months however many
months it is now
is that you know a lot of the policies
that we've been
advocating have been really good for
the kinds of people that do the kind of
scientific work that goes behind the
policy making
i mean there was this there was this
stuff in in science studies
uh that was quite popular in the 1980s
called
interest modeling and the idea was like
it was in sociology science the idea was
you
you explain every you explain every
episode of the history of science
in terms of like the scientists just
reached the conclusions that were good
for them
and you know the classic case was like
19th century victorian work into
eugenics right that was like the
the the um the the typical example of
interest modeling
and i you know i at the time i didn't i
didn't sort of wasn't a big fan of that
stuff and
in general i'm not necessarily a big fan
of that of that way of thinking about
the history of science in general
but but it's felt pretty strongly to me
over the last year that that's
you know that we have we have instituted
policies over the over the last 16
months that have effectively
you know diverted the virus away towards
everybody but you know upper middle
class
knowledge workers um and i don't think
that's a
i don't think that's a massive
coincidence uh
so um i think it isn't i think that's
the that is the money question
like stephanie's last question on the
slide here but i don't know what the
answer is but i definitely think
uh this is this is a crucial thing to be
talking about
if science is going to be informing
policy
is how do we make sure that the
epistemic standards being used in that
scientific work
uh you know are representing the values
of all the stakeholders because it's
it's uh it's it's pretty clear to me at
least
that um you know what we've seen over
the last
several months has not been something
where you know
the science has been done in a kind of
cool dispassionate way
that just just you know being
informative so that then policymakers
can
that's our standard picture right the
scientists are supposed to just give us
the information
and the policy makers are supposed to
represent the interests of their
stakeholders and combine those interests
with that knowledge
and pick policy um that first part
didn't just didn't i don't think played
out that way this year so
i think it is time i think it is you
know we we we need to be having more and
more of that conversation
okay i think i'll let um other people
jump into the conversation
um thank you so much um eric for
uh that detailed sort of response and
engagement with some of the really
important questions that um
stephanie um has raised so um
i think um i wanted to take the liberty
of sort of opening up the
to the floor with a question myself
and you know and i think i wanted to
come back to this idea that both of you
had uh have touched upon which is the
purposes of
modeling right and clarity about the
purpose
of modeling and and that it's almost
uh that the purpose of the purpose that
you are modeling either to make
predictions for practical
reasons in terms of resource management
in the case of covid it was to ensure
that you know there are enough hospital
beds in particular cities and regions so
that was sort of
driving uh that kind of resource uh
availability and assessment was driving
it
um i was curious about what you both
felt about how do we how do we
present the motive for
modeling in a more clear-cut transparent
way
i mean there are of course always going
to be people with agendas who will want
to
read into it no matter how you state
what your purpose is how clearly you
state what your purpose is
but i was wondering if there if you both
had some thoughts
about you know how could we have a bit
more transparency
in uh at least the motives for you know
a particular model
and the presentation of a model in a
particular way
eric do you want to go first no i
thought maybe you'd take that one first
okay i do have some thoughts on this
matter particularly in health economics
because
very often people will talk about
models in health economics as being for
the purpose of prediction
and in fact one of the major guideline
documents about health economics
modeling has a line
that happens to get me a little worked
up
which is that ultimately what matters
is that a a model reproduces what
happens in reality
and and i'm only paraphrasing very
slightly right
and i think that in a lot of contexts
we're not going to get there right and
eric i imagine that you agree
right because what we're trying to do um
is predict a system that probably defies
prediction really at any meaningful
level right
particularly in the context of for
example um
very often you know particularly in
canada we do two clinical trials to
evaluate a new drug
and then we do simulation models to try
to anticipate
what the costs and the benefits are
going to be to the health system
of making this drug available to the
public
now we all know the limitations of
randomized controlled trials right
they're conducted under conditions
that are not like the ones that exist in
the real world so
to just imagine that you're going to be
able to take that evidence
and put it into a simulation model and
have a good grip on what's really going
to happen
i don't have a lot of confidence in that
process
um you know further to that
i think to be able to make meaningful
predictions you'd have to have a way of
testing whether they panned out
right and we don't really do that right
in the in the canadian healthcare system
once they invest in a particular drug
they don't do rigorous studies to say
okay well now
now that we've invested in it what has
happened right so
in my own opinion i don't think it's
quite right to say that the purpose of
those models
is prediction i don't think that's well
put i think it's
better to say that the purpose of that
model is to inform decisions
right and i think the next step then is
to talk about
under what conditions people are wanting
to make decisions
and what their attitude is to
uncertainty because
there there are some really important
normative questions that need to be
answered there
and there's the dominant line of
thinking and health economics that
basically
says you should just not mind
uncertainty
and you should go with what looks like
the best bet
turning a blind eye to the uncertainty
that you have and
you know some folks might agree that
that's the best way to do it i don't
happen to agree
which i think underscores that that's
actually kind of a moral judgment
right so i think that we need to
actually do
a better job of articulating the purpose
of the model do a better job of
fleshing out our relevant attitudes
um and then having more public debate
around
how we want to do this because you could
probably do it in way more
ways than we're ever even getting on the
table
right i just want to add one quick thing
to that which is that
i just don't even get the idea that the
purpose
of a policy guiding model is prediction
because after all policy choices are
always choices between at least two
alternatives
and so just being able to predict what
happens under
one particular policy choice is totally
uninformative
i need to know what would have happened
under the other possible
policy choice and that's not prediction
uh and and you know i mean
i've had a few debates about you know
i'm sort of well-known
i get hysterical about the imperial
college model and report nine and
the stage group and some people like to
point out oh they you know they actually
predicted the course the epidemic rather
well into certain countries
well yes i mean they predicted it really
well in the countries that followed
their advice because
in their model they you know they've
vastly overstated
the fatality of the virus and vastly
overstated the effectiveness of
the policies that they recommended so
obviously in places where people
followed exactly their policy
those cancelled out and their
predictions were great but the
predictions for let's say you know
sweden or for florida and and were bad
and their predictions for
for for developing countries were
horrible uh and it's just it's not you
know to say oh well we predicted what
was going to happen in the uk reason
would be well
that's that's totally uninformative i
want to know
what your i want to know what your full
the full spectrum of your counter
factual
projections was because that's what
informs policy predictions don't inform
policy
um but yeah and then i i i yeah
yeah so i think um thank you both
i think that they um i i perhaps
one way to have seen these predictions
that were made
is simply seeing them as maps of
possibilities
maps of possibilities and you know and i
think the problem
with the narratives of public narratives
is that
because people don't really understand
what uncertainty inherent uncertainty
means and what a lack of
knowledge of evolving sort of the
provisional nature of
figuring stuff out about the virus
itself was uh hindering us
from really uh getting a grip i think
that you know what might have been
useful
was like you know a map of uh potential
scenarios
and then discuss policy interventions
in the context of a range of these
product projections and not as you all
said to fixate on one and say well
how can we um but i wanted to come back
because stephanie brought this up you
know and
a little bit of clarification and from
your experience and expertise
my impression as a person who works in a
field where you know we don't really do
randomized controlled trials but you
know i sort of follow it because they
are seen as the gold standard
and so on and in astronomy there are
people who aspire to do
randomized control styles in terms of
selecting
uh image identification and
classification
and so on so forth but to the technique
itself
is it isn't it true that the whole
methodology
um assumes that you have
independent non-interleaved causes
and that you can therefore isolate them
if you have compound
causes um and if you don't
know what all causes are possible
i mean our cities are no good right i
mean i was just curious you know what i
really seen are
do people in health in particular
because you know that's where these are
sort of the gold standard
are the limitations of these techniques
also being sort of uh
actively studied now i think
definitely the limitations of our cts
are more and more attended to
and and in particular i think the
language gold standard is definitely on
the way out i think there are definitely
people that
that uh you know still use that but and
i i could be mixing up my
fields here i know philosophers of
science do not use that term anymore and
they have good reasons for not using it
um so there are again yeah like a few
assumptions that we have to
go on if we're gonna regard our cts as
being extremely
you know if we're gonna use language
like gold standard it's because we think
um you know all the confounders are are
randomly assigned they're not affecting
things right and of course
you can't really you can't ever prove
that it could be the case that there are
confiners that you're not measuring and
they weren't randomly they didn't happen
to balance out right randomization
probably balances it out but it doesn't
doesn't ascertain it for sure
um but i think the thing to focus on
even more is
is about this again what is the purpose
of the randomized control trial
and in what respect does it not
suffice for purposes that actually we
deem very important right
so the rct is answering a different
question altogether
it's answering this question if for
example in the context of a drug
does this drug work under perfect
conditions that's the question
and at some point the relevance of that
question expires
and we're not interested in that anymore
we're interested about whether it's
working for us in the real world and
then we really get into a lot of
challenges
because we're into this well now we're
in the real world and there's all sorts
of crazy stuff going on and we don't
know
what we have to control for and it's
very different types of folks
who are taking those drugs and and we
lose track of
you know are they taking it as
prescribed are they interacting maybe
and other things they're taking at the
same time
and so on and so on and so on um
so yeah i think it really does
underscore that we have to understand
the different purposes
and as well we have to understand our
limitations because
it's true that once you bump into that
observational study context
then you're facing all the problems that
you know eric and i just went through in
terms of
well now you don't have that benefit of
at least randomization seems effective
for
maybe balancing out compounders eric
just real quick i mean this i'm just
immediately summarizing what stephanie
said but look
randomized control is great it's a great
thing to be able to do
but it also imposes costs like suppose
you wanted to do randomized control
on the effectiveness of masks right
you could do that let's say let's say
you got around certain ethical you know
issues on that you did it well what
would that look like because what that
would look like
you'd get a bunch of people you'd make
some of them wear masks and you'd
you know send them into certain
controlled conditions and then see
how they compared to the people who
didn't wear the masks now you're going
to eliminate a lot of compounds there
right you probably eliminate all the
compounds
but you're looking at a very narrow set
of circumstances you're not then seeing
whether
you know you're getting you're just
determining what mass
use does in this very narrow constrained
set of circumstances
that your trial is taking place and
which might not be that informative
about what happens
when you know people are expected to
wear masks for eight hour shifts or
children are asked to wear masks in
schools or you know
excited sorry you can't possibly do an
rct
in which all of the you know all of the
sort of
in the wild phenomena are being studied
right so
observational studies do have a number
of advantages over rcts because they are
they do take place in the wild but of
course then they have all their
compounds etc
so there's no magic bullet right and i
think that as you said in this in this
kind of mass study example that you just
gave
i mean the the idea that you are
marginalizing over all
other variables even in a
controlled study is clearly observed
because two different people
with different genetic physiological
underlying proclivities conditions
are going to react differently to the
same level of exposure or lack thereof
right and so
we know that already we know that about
all our bodies
that that there isn't one metric
that uh can represent any kind of
risk x because the marginalization
over all other variables just doesn't
work i mean it really doesn't work
uh i think we should move on to the
questions and i would like to first
um see the floor to sort of two
questions from chris who
um has been engaging with us offline as
well and
so he says that he has two questions
that are similar to the
third question that stephanie raised
which first that policy makers are faced
with a comparative assessment how do we
compare models with
other sources of evidence regarding the
effects of policy
interventions they could still be the
best of a very bad
lot of possibilities second looking
forward
how could we do better at drawing these
kinds of causal inferences
are there different kinds of data that
public health agencies should be
gathering for example
uh so i'll start with the sec yeah let
me
i'll start with the second uh question
because i think that's a little easier
um so so the second question
i think there are two things that that i
i've been sort of pressing for
over the last uh several months one is
i don't think that we i think we did too
much changing our mind about the
received
wisdom over the course of this pandemic
there were you know
there were there were there were a
number of you know
sort of standard procedures in the cdc
for doing things and they
they said things like you know don't
close schools for more than six weeks
um uh you know etc and
we very quickly decided in this pandemic
i think in part because we were watching
what looked like we thought we knew was
going on in china we thought like this
is so different
we need to just rip up the playbook and
and we need to just be
making all these wild inferences on the
fly and guiding policy with
and i and i don't think that was i don't
think that was super wise i think
you know i think science is is done good
science is done slowly
uh and it's done you know with with with
pure criticism and it's done with
stakeholders having uh voice etc so so
that was part of it and then yeah i mean
early on also very early on the pandemic
i think we were doing a lot of modeling
with very poor information
about uh what you know the outcome of
the virus was in different age groups
uh et cetera and there that there could
that was that would have been that was
that was an easy fix right we could have
been
doing a lot more uh you know um
uh serology testing to figure out you
know how many people have been infected
it's kind of a scandal i think that i
just you know i obsess over this stuff
um and i don't really have a good feel
for how many americans have
been infected with i think it's probably
somewhere between 100 million and 150
million
but that's a that's a probably
the uncertainty gap is wider than that
that's my that's where i put mine
and already that's appallingly large we
just should know more than that we could
have known more than that we could have
been doing a lot more
spot testing random spot testing doing
more serology testing
getting a better feel for how many
people have been affected which would
have given us
early on a much better uh sense of what
the
you know uh what the danger of the
violence i placed on different age
groups
trying to uh which might have had us
adopting quite different policies with
protected schools i think
in the developed world i think our the
way we've handled schools has been
you know pretty appalling there was a
really good piece in the new york times
uh last week that i'll try to share at
some point i think everybody should read
just about how
scandalous the way we've handled uh
schools
uh in this in this country has been over
the last uh
year and a half so um so yeah so that's
that's i think that was your second
question chris
your first question was uh oh right what
do we do when it's the best out of
a bad group of laws um i think this gets
to stephanie's question about like when
does research have negative expected
utility
and i think the answer certainly is
sometimes i think sometimes
the best the best science out of uh you
know a bad lot might just be better left
not done
or at least not or at least not um
at least not paraded around right uh
in a way that suggests it's um
you know uh but i mean you know we've
had we've had
a lot of we've had a lot of rhetoric uh
in the last year and a half about how
various policies are following science i
mean that's really makes it sound
like um two things one that there's very
little uncertainty in the science and
that's crazy
and second that there's like you know
some some deterministic mapping from
what the output of the science is to
like what the right policies are
and that's also crazy so so yeah i don't
know when
when when you've got you know um you've
got you know the least bad method
available
what should you do i think that's a
tough question and i think
when that happens i think when that
happens um you know all
the things stephanie was talking about
about public participation
and about you know uh including i think
the more you know the more uncertainty
you have
the more the more you're selecting from
you know the least bad model from
the least bad method from a barrel of
bad methods
um the more you need to be paying
attention to the fact that
uh there you're you're in in grave
danger
of um of you know
putting forward both knowledge and
recommendations of
policies that favor some stakeholders
over others
thank you um stephanie did you want to
add anything
um um
i i think i've lost i've lost the nugget
that i would reply to so maybe we should
move on to the next one and i'll weigh
in on that one
okay great so the next question
was um by sinji kumar on causal
discovery
and the extent to which it is about the
search for right counterfactuals
and that it is largely a social process
so the role of
mentors communities connections and
networks
so is this social learning aspect that
does not get sufficiently emphasized
as a way non-linearity gets factored in
and this may not be amenable to modeling
at all but how but we do need to
acknowledge it
and what are your thoughts about
how how to take that into account
i guess i'm not exactly familiar with
what the question is
talking about stephanie is that
um i'm going to take a stab at replying
to that and if i'm off the mark just let
me know
um i i also i'm i'm unfamiliar with some
of the terms in that question but the
part that i'm i think i'm picking up is
is really important
has to do with the fact that you do not
have to model every question
and i think that's exactly right and i
think that like
part of what really interests me is
having more open conversations about
like what is it that we want to model
like when we talk about ourselves as a
community in so far as is possible
like which questions do which
communities want to approach
with a modeling strategy i think it's
wrong
to be pretending that every single
question has to be approached in this
in this fashion and it does connect to
what eric's talking about in terms of
the negative expected utility of
of research in certain contexts right so
for example i think sometimes we find
ourselves facing a problem that it is
very new
it's going to take some time to figure
out and maybe we do want to assign
some scientists the role of slowly
figuring that out but that doesn't
mean that we we don't have to figure out
um policies
for now for the interim right and i
think that it would be okay
in some context to say okay as a
community what are we gonna do
we don't have good information right now
let's acknowledge that
and let's just um think about what our
goals are
and see if we can get on the same page
about what we really want to achieve
and whether we can come up with
strategies to achieve those goals that
allow us to avail ourselves of
information that we think is
really good quality okay and i'm
thinking in the context of health
like there's a whole debate about what
health even is
right and if we want to achieve like
like in covid
ostensibly what people are really
worried about is people's health
right well there are lots of things that
society drops the ball on
all the time in terms of failing
people's health right but that doesn't
mean they're because we have poor
information about how to maximize
people's health right
so without having and don't get me wrong
i'm not trying to take this
too too far but there are simple things
that society wasn't doing prior to covid
anyway and it might have made sense in
some
more moral conversations to say okay
well we have a pandemic going on what
are some strategies that
probably regardless of uncertainty we
could feel good about
pursuing could we feel good about
pursuing more
sick days for people i think you could
come up with a conversation that was
really just normative in nature
that said yes in this context i think we
can feel good about investing in sick
days
maybe we can feel good about investing
in strategies to make sure there's not
overcrowding in certain areas
so those are just some questions that i
would bring up like in terms of
if we in some contexts want to shy away
from modeling
what would replace it i think some
public deliberation
could go some ways
okay no thank you um
i wanted to move on to the next question
uh which i'm going to have to interpret
a little bit and that i think
has to do with how do we build uh and
construct epistemic
trust
yeah we got a lot of bridges to fix uh i
think about epistemic trust
i think you know look part of the reason
i brought up some of these
somewhat silly causal inferences uh
yesterday things like you know
you know that the motorcycle rally
caused
35 of the cases in the united states
over the course of two weeks that
you know um uh that trump voting
counties were the ones where they were
the most
coveted cases etc etc is i mean this is
incredibly this is incredibly
that people aren't people aren't stupid
right i mean um
you know people aren't rubes people know
that uh they're the wolves being pulled
over their eyes with
with stuff like that and it's incredibly
i think damaging to scientific trust uh
to engage in that stuff and i it's you
know i i it was an election year people
were very passionate about
um this last election for reasons i
understand very well
but uh it was alarming to me i think
that people were willing to sort of
throw scientific trust under the boss
for that um i don't know what we can do
i don't know what we can do
to uh to repair it uh
stephanie you have any thoughts
yeah i mean i guess i i do i feel s
somewhat uh well i don't know if
optimistic is the right word but i think
one of the strategies to invest in is
more public participation in science of
course this has been said by many many
many people
but i think that it takes on an
additional importance when it comes to
this really complex modeling that's
going on
i i happen to work in more than one
initiative that
this is the goal right is talking to
folks about modeling going on
and i've met a lot of people who the
knowledge isn't even there that those
are techniques that are being used
right so i don't think that's right i
think that they have a huge influence on
society
and that it's not right for science as
an establishment
to sort of just take off at high speeds
and do a lot of this problem solving
using these strategies without making
that additional
effort to engage with publics and say
hey you know we have these
strategies that we're using and this is
how they work and and one of the things
that i think is important is that
when you're uh given a chance to explain
your methods
to lots of different people at lots of
different levels
you know you can actually force yourself
to look at some challenges
right because you can get some tough
questions oh well how do you show this
oh well actually we can't you know we
have to rely on this assumption or that
assumption
and those are the types of conversations
that i mean i don't know i'm not an
expert in what exactly builds trust
but speaking from my own personal
perspective when i talk to scientists
um i really want to be able to know that
they can tell me what it is that they're
doing
and be honest about like where is it
that are we having to make assumptions
and what are the gaps and so on so
i think there's a huge push to be very
very fast about a lot of things and i
think some of the solution is probably
down the road of being a bit slower
yeah um thank you so
moving on to the next question um
the question is that they want to this
is ted boston and he wants to pick up
again on the role of knowledge of causal
mechanisms in connection with eric's
skeptical argument about inferring
causation from the data
exhibited by non-linear systems so he
says that he worries that the argument
proves
too much if it's difficult to infer
causal relationships from data as for
example
the global warming hiatus example then
it's difficult to infer causal
relationships from climate data of the
past hundred years
the last hundred years is a blip
compared to the millions of years of
climate data
as climate warming um skeptics argue
there are blips over many years in which
the earth warms and cools
perhaps we find ourselves in a warming
blip the reply to this line
stresses that we shouldn't rely on the
data but our causal knowledge
of the role of co2 in the atmosphere
yet if that's the correct response to
the global warming skeptic
then it seems a defense of masking and
social distancing
can rely on our knowledge of the causal
mechanisms of how
respiratory diseases are spread so the
general issue here
is whether we are ever in a position to
infer a causal relationship with data
from non-linear systems
in the short term perhaps without the
entire historical data set
without some background knowledge of
causal mechanisms
good so so let me start with that
climate case right i mean
i think it would be a mistake to think
that the reason that
we think global warming is happening is
merely
seeing the data and knowing that carbon
dioxide is a heat trapping gas
because after all right heat trapping
gases um produce feedbacks in the
atmosphere
right when when the actual warms that
releases more moisture
moisture is also heat trapping it
creates clouds clouds are sometimes heat
trapping sometimes keep releasing
it changes the lapse rate in the
atmosphere that is you know
can could be heat trapping or heat uh
releasing that's a complicated question
um it melts ice ice creates albedo so
that so there are all these feedbacks
and we have you know i think a pretty we
have a pretty
um we have a pretty detailed
understanding of some of that we don't
just have like okay here's a simple
mechanism
okay now so let's take the idea that
like well what do we know about the
mechanism of like viral transmission
well it's actually pretty complicated
right i mean viral transmission
is is fluid dynamics really right
and um i mean uh
so i don't it's not it's not you know
some of the people who uh were the most
expert in this
right i mean i can uh uh this will be
another link i'll share when i get a
chance
um some of the people who were most
expert on this were warning early on
um you know these cloth masks don't like
if we
are based on our understanding of the
mechanism these cloth masks are not
likely to work
right um because yeah everybody's worn
one knows
immediately if you wear glasses and one
of these masks they fog up your glasses
so um just saying okay we know that we
just saying we know
viruses or things that get exhaled from
the mouth and nose
therefore if you cover your mouth and
nose that's enough that's enough
knowledge of the mechanism to then
know that you know this is going to be
an effective method in fact a lot of the
people
with the most expert knowledge of that
were warning early on
let's not let's not get people too much
uh you know uh of course you know
the thing about mass of course was
nobody because it was such a sort of you
know mild intervention
nobody wanted to be like oh no this is
terrible don't do that
because you know but i do think a lot of
people were trying to warn
don't think this is some kind of magic
bullet right
don't don't think that this can
substitute for spending less time
indoors with other people um and so you
know the mechanism there was is
complicated
and in fact right some of the people i
think were most knowledgeable about the
about the sort of you know airflow and
and all that were
kind of raising alarms about this early
on and
um in fact were they were in effect
trumped to some extent
by some of these some of these uh causal
inference methods
so it's a complicated story the whole
mask thing is a complicated story
and i think one of the things that
really complicates it and i'm
sympathetic to this i mean i really
am uh you know one of the things that
complicates it was like look this is
such a small ask
right we're just asking you to put a
piece of cloth over your mouth
and so i think that the dynamics of that
were complicated but
um if we're just if we're just thinking
about this sort of you know coolly and
dispassionately from the point of
view of scientific inference i don't i
don't i don't think that the sort of you
know
physical mechanism reasoning there was
was really
that good for thinking that that cloth
masks were effective
after all you have to you know you have
to be able to breathe through them and
can't just you know it's not like
putting a plastic bag over your head so
stephanie did you want to
um i no i think i'll leave that one to
eric i have no expertise in
climate science and i think i would end
up just repeating myself in terms of
um you know the the message that we do
have to have
some conversations about decision making
under uncertainty given that people are
just gonna have
different takes you know about when when
we're going to conclude that something
is one way or the other right like
there there are always going to be folks
that are like
i don't i don't think that you know
anything causes global warming that
humans can control right there's always
going to be some of those those folks um
so i don't know i think i would end up
underlining that again
all right thank you ty did you want to
see if there are any further questions
sorry muted um okay
i think you answer i've answered suda's
right lakshmi's
question about complete lockdown
okay and
i guess i don't think we had jenny jenny
wagner's questioning
did we uh does it help to decide which
subsequent intervention to take
when it already when already having had
an intervention in order to fix some
initial conditions
to make evolution models less complex
that was towards the beginning of the
chat let me see if i can copy it
i guess this was about the purposes of
models it was relevant to that
set of questions earlier sure look i
mean there's a there's you know there's
a simple
very you know very simple like if you're
trying to fix something
um you're supposed to do one thing at a
time right like let's say you know your
computer's not working right
you know jiggle this chord first see if
that works then set that down jiggle the
other thing
if you're trying six or seven different
interventions all the same time it's
going to be hard
it's going to be hard to pull apart um
you know which ones are
which ones are working or which ones are
that's as an added level of complexity
if they're
you know every place is trying all these
different interventions at the same time
of makes it very hard to figure out
if you think that as a group they're
being effective maybe
which one is working that that's that's
extra hard
i i take it maybe that was the question
i'm not sure
so then there's another question that's
just uh come up which is
you know the relevance of the concept of
contingency
as a way to not evade the
representational risk
well that's an interesting what is the
relevance of the concept
of contingency you have to say a little
more for me on that
uh francisco did you want to type a
little bit more explaining what you
had in mind
let me see if they're still there and
might unmute them
i think he's i'm thinking in the concept
well let me unmute i've asked to unmute
them
um let's see
ty could you unmute them yep um well
i i can only ask him to unmute so i'm
doing that
uh okay he's added a few more lines
yeah i have to say i don't
i don't quite get the connection so he's
thinking in the concept of steven j
gold's structure theory
i'm not thinking of anything brilliant
to say back to that unfortunately
sorry so um are there any other
questions does anyone else have any
other questions please feel free to type
before we wrap up
so i think there's one question that's
just come up
that has to do um
with something that came up yesterday in
your talk eric and it's about the
abadi's
dilemma as it arose in jaina
i took it that one of the horns was the
worry that if you are comparing jaina to
places similar enough to jaina to make
for good comparisons
then they may also be influenced by mask
mandates and jaina my question is can
this lead to mistakes in either
direction
or only underestimation of the effects
of mass
mandates well i'll just tell you when
what what i think typically happened
right and you can see this in spades
in the in the south dakota in the
motorcycle rally case
so um what you know what they did in a
motorcycle rally cases said oh we want
to be
we we when we pick our control for for
south dakota
we want we're not going to use any
neighboring states because
that might you know that might involve
bleed over from people leaving
on their motorcycles and so they went
with you know
they went with far away states and that
gave them like a lot of flexibility if
you look
i've been trying to piece this through
since yesterday it's been a while since
i looked at that one
but um they ended up using quite a bit
of
hawaii in the donor pool for figuring
out what the
what the synthetic control for south
dakota was
now obviously right that in that case
what's that going to do that's going to
make it look like the motorcycle rally
you know had a large causal effect
so i think i i think to some extent
right
in the in when you have those two
constraints are cheaters that are out of
right one
one that says go look far afield
when you go look far afield it just
gives you flexibility
right so that if the researcher is then
either not careful
or has an axe to grind it just it just
i think opens a pathway to either
overestimating or underestimating
depending on how you how you pick the
donor pool
does that kind of answer your question
it does it just makes me wonder uh how
things change if you um
uh go in the other direction so if you
compared south dakota to similar states
then there'd be a worry that like you
say maybe there's bleed over
but then that it seems to me that that
would mostly
create risks of underestimation of the
effect so if you still found a big
effect
that might be informative right
typically
in my experience having looked at a
bunch of these synthetic control methods
they were all erring in the other
direction so yeah i imagine that's
probably right if you aired
in in if you aired in your direction
you'd probably you'd probably
be um risking underestimating the the
effect
and i think that's why i think that's
why right and
over the all the ones that were at least
being accepted for publication
it was usually like look you know we're
showing through a pronounced
uh effect of the intervention and we're
doing it by being really careful to go
with far
field um and of course as we all know
like you know after
having watched the epidemic go for for
18 months i think
most people can recognize that um
allowing yourself to look far
feel geographically uh just just you
know
allows you to construct synthetic
controls that could sort of show
anything you want them to show
like if you can use if you can use
hawaii as a comparator for south dakota
you know i think all bets are off
great um looks like uh
there are no further questions uh so i
would like to
take this opportunity to say thank you
to both
uh stephanie and eric for this wonderful
conversation
and you know many many
complex uh ideas that are going to be
quite
hard but very important to address in
what we are really trying to do
with uh modeling be it in climate
science or enhance economics
thank you both very much for these
wonderful perspectives
and thanks everyone for attending
uh we look forward to seeing you all at
the
next convening the july convening of our
in france colloquium
uh speaker series and our speaker will
be
uh professor elise crowe from um
um the ccny so uh thanks everyone
bye and have a lovely weekend